le liban à présent où le camp chrétien
se regroupent autour de michel aoun le
général destitué a aujourd'hui a été
pardon destitue aujourd'hui par le
président hraoui et la menace d'une
intervention syrienne se confirme
d'heure en heure les troupes se
concentre autour du palais présidentiel
de baabda où michel aoun et les siens
ont donc décidé de faire bloc la france
a dépêché sur place un émissaire la
france qui rappelle son attachement à
toute forme de réconciliation nationale
à l'exclusion bien sûr de la violence
joël hasard
depuis la nuit dernière par milliers les
chrétiens libanais déferlent sur le
palais présidentiel de baabda les femmes
les enfants les familles des partisans
du général aoun tous au premier rang
pour clamer leur soutien et réductible
au chef du réduit chrétiens tous prêts à
mourir s'il le faut dit il en cas d'
attaque sur bagdad
les jeunes s'enrôlent le pays chrétien
se préparent la bataille
acheteurs à dans le sens du liban sous
contrôle syrien le gouvernement libanais
tentent d'imposer son autorité en
l'absence des ministres chrétiens en
limogeant le général aoun le président
hraoui a fait le pari de rallier une
majorité de militaires chrétien ou
nouveau commandement en chef de l'armée
pour le liban je suis engagé pour tous
sa souveraineté pour son indépendance et
pour qu'il n'y ait plus sur le
territoire libanais que l'armée
libanaise togruta c'est le mairie ps qui
va régner au liban surtout des futurs
débats sur la ligne de démarcation des
routes la 6e brigade musulmane de
l'armée libanaise tenté aujourd'hui une
démonstration de force en réalité les
véritables pressions se joue ailleurs
sur les fronts de montagne autour de
pays chrétien là où des mouvements de
troupes et de blindés syriens se
poursuivent ce soir si gouvernement
libanais est engagé une bataille
fratricide les trous spéciale de damas
risquent elles de prendre le relais